oh man I'm fired up come on man I'm fine
famous you say well it's different now
dude you did you know what I can direct
and different no it's just different now
for those of you that didn't see the
video I posted on the Instagram Brandon
Brandon put this out it's random Brendan
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry forgetting I
had been so swamped brother I've been so
swamped can we put your phone away oh
sorry I was just looking at the video
that we post man I thought you're
texting your famous agent I was and I'm
just I'm so busy but I'm gonna make it
to this podcast as often as I possibly
can sound very promising it's going to
be promising I can't do it this year
time y'all tuck major roles Luis I just
start driving around town going see you
suckers but I'm not going anywhere
so long notice one suckers yeah so how'd
it go down man but it's for those you're
like what the [ __ ] happened Brian got a
show thirteen episodes twelve episodes
13 episodes 13 episode this is big the
big as you get getting your own sitcom
on NBC ABC yes at NBC sorry Z well you
know like I was saying when you've been
doing this as long as I have as you know
we talked about this you get so many
knows and life is that really don't know
yeah but but but but I'm saying you know
my career oh yeah I know your career I'm
sorry I don't know the you know say like
you've had a lot of yeses man oh but
keep going but but but for sure like
when you do this for as long as I have
you're always gonna have a lot of nose
it's just the nature of the business man
Latanya and I think in life let's be
honest with you and I've always talked
about that like there are a lot of knows
man I mean you try really hard and you
just you don't make it you don't win and
so you get that yes you know and what's
funny about it is that I had been doing
this song that I didn't ever I just
stopped thinking about it and people
were asked me about and it would remind
me like you'd say any word and I'd be
like and I literally thought I would
like text you every day any word could
add a dream you got it I text you I
remember that's right that's right so
nothing brothers if they take the time
what do how to dream last night you got
it yeah I'll say that dream you
jacking me off but I understand I
understand well when I did our Joey nose
hit this is so weird the wheels hit in
LA from West Palm Beach no no no no
short flight not a short flight sir
because I had to stop in Atlanta not a
short flight were you private at this
point yet or no I do fly only private I
don't fly with an almond cattle Oh got
you because the common folk because the
common folk are disgusting refer to us
as civilians I don't want their poor
juice on the Opry okay but III at the
minute the wheels hit the tarmac I get a
call and it's Doug Robinson who is who
runs Happy Madison productions you right
oh yeah out of Sandwich TV that yeah
he's Doug is a stud and a great guy and
he basically and Doug's always believed
in me Doug said dude if it was up to me
you would have been working you know and
Doug Doug caught was called with Adam
Goldberg and Mark Furyk who wrote the
pilot and they were just like guess what
dude it's a yes 13 episode what do you
do well I was a pretty cool I was on a
plane so I just said first of all I said
I owe it to you guys thank you and then
now if you hadn't come up with the
character I was like listen man you guys
made it so easy and it's always that and
did you demand more money right there
you don't wait for that my age okay good
good that's fantastic here's my daily
maid Fame I would just start pushing
people in the face I play out certain
servants more wine here bro wine please
and but you are happy yeah it was it's
the text me got the part bro or got it
brother of the oh [ __ ] again it's it's
great but again it's it's this is what
we do now it's it's fun it's more work
it's great and as long as I'm having fun
and I'm making people laugh it's good
work I think it's important to and tell
me if I'm completely off on this I don't
think now hear me out here yeah you can
get dark for your time I don't mind tell
me this if you didn't get this role not
that you wouldn't been happy but you're
kind of when you came to LA it was to be
a successful actor not you know even on
the gold bridge most people say that
successful yeah
Sex in the City entourage
all the movies you've done someone say
yet successful career you don't think
someone I wouldn't you would not and
because you're not whatever whoever you
compare yourself to but I think if you
didn't get this you would have never
felt satisfied I think you'd have felt
like your failure as an actor which and
acting by nature is your is your basis
yeah like if this is mixed martial arts
and you're you grew up wrestling yes and
be your base you're good at everything
yeah you're amazing fighter and
everything yeah you can do it all
Taekwondo boxing Jiu Jitsu wrestling's
your bench my happy place acting's your
happy place
you're one of the best stand-up in the
world you're phenomenal podcaster a
terrible teeth but you [ __ ] you're
acting is your home base you get a
little too happy and sassy and my buddy
Marshall all had those they would they
complimented me I'll read them to you
and then but there's always those jabs
in the middle yeah for the most part I
might as that fear be like I'm yelling
go oh I want to be a great stair can ya
know they say well I think what it is is
it's a nice milestone i shooting my
special in july i got my own show that
these were goals i had written down and
it's just nice to have realized that
it's very nice to have you there's
something about life where you draw a
line through those through those things
you wrote down for yourself
my heart's not as black as yours yet
because when you went hey they shot the
pilot
oh you're gets going I guarantee like
dude like I'm the exhaustion friends
like it's going yeah yeah it's going
like no well I don't even listen to it I
mean I've been able to you know again
I'm very fulfilled with my podcast with
my stand-up so and and with the
Goldbergs remember I've been I've been
working a lot of seasons on the Gulf War
yeah so I had a full plate but this is
just a beautiful super plate yeah this
is a carrot how do you the main course
yeah everywhere else you you're the
little side they came to me I want to
expect your Phonographic yeah I'm like
the Madsen know they get mad it's
[ __ ] nobody I can't we know right now
I got like whatever you want now like
I'm like your career like if we're
serving dinner you've always been like
I'll have some coleslaw your the side
and then like everyone's the meat yeah
on finding the kid like you're the
cranberry sauce right and then
I'm a turkey like Goldberg you're the
stuffing but now you hear that prime rib
in the middle well that was fun you you
come up with a character you show up on
set
it's supposed to be just a recurring
role that you know maybe maybe a one-off
it turns into a four year gig a year ago
they said we're thinking about doing a
spin-off of Coach Mellor and it happened
I think it's the thing entertainment
people go it's not like a week go
they're like hey Bryan was thing about
doing a spin-off here let's do this it's
like the wheels in motion for anything
to happen there's so many different
factors that even you know way more than
I do but just from my experience there's
so many it's like it the little spark
started how long ago and then [ __ ]
that's wombs into this flower but that
spark those get put out like this like
this like this boy I know in those parts
years yeah like right even before they
told you probably years ago like man we
probably do something to spin-off and so
has to ride and some goes okay this will
fit here then the timing then the
timeslot then the network and then the
executives and then the creative dress
that can be available Aaron Sorkin was
talking they're inserting a social
network a few good men loved them wrote
West Wing created West Wing I mean a bee
sting movie I mean a beast and he he
said it takes him at least this is a guy
who's known to write quickly and
prolifically at least two years to write
a script at least and then then you've
got the casting then you've got the
production then he five years at least
you write I mean everything takes that
long and maybe it should I don't know
how to write I'm this this this one hour
it started really gel in West Palm
Saturday night because I just keep
coming back it that's taken me since I
shot my last one what when was that two
years ago Yeah right
it at least it takes a long time and
that's working in our do you ever do you
ever do this do you ever just go I don't
know what I'm doing when you're writing
jokes or yes just like I don't know what
I'm doing yes well I the best advice I
got recently from Ed Solomon wrote
Madame black and everything else said
write with your body
your brain follow be emotional right
from where you feel again what are you
ashamed of what are you afraid of yeah
you know who you pretending to be what
do you all those things those what are
the central questions in your brain
what's your primary questions and right
from there you know so it's 13 episodes
you get paid per up so yeah yeah
removing or what do we do with the money
buying a yacht
but if you just went crazy rapper rich I
have jay-z money daddy went yeah no no
I'll just keep my not small and I'll pay
off some bills you know when you get
when you get a show like that dude
my brains [ __ ] up cuz my grid below
the belt my god help their season too as
soon as on the first the first time like
god help your season - yeah well
although it's a ton of work there's a
great book I'm reading now by Sam Harris
the [ __ ] brilliant he's done Brogan's
pocket right and he wrote a book called
spirituality without religion and Sam
Harris which I didn't know he did he's
been a he's been he's a really he prays
that the great god of rationality he's a
famous atheist but super famous but he
is a he
he's been meditating for 20 years and he
goes on retreats with serious like
Tibetan Buddhist Monson and he's a deep
deep and he wrote a book on meditation
and one of the things that kind of
struck me was he was talking about how
as human beings we always go from want
to want to want to want always always
right if you think about it they sleep
oh and when you're always wanting you're
not you're not present and you're not
actually enjoying and you and I have a
problem with this and everybody has a
problem this because we are we are
always what we're yeah I got this next
and we never stop and that's what I told
you when I wouldn't you got this below
the belt I want we need to take a minute
stop and you said this to me stop this
is a big milestone let's have a meal
let's have a laugh let's stop and think
about not only where we've come but what
we built because it has been and we
don't do that we're never because now
that I want more I take oh no what if it
doesn't you know
another episode Tech's Amanda cuz I
figure maybe she get the wheels of
motion to get us together do a meal yeah
I'm like we have to celebrate counting
his own [ __ ] sitcom gotta do
something
yes she's like oh you know she didn't
take the wreck no cuz she knew I was low
she talked to her I got probably not and
she goes and then she goes do you make
over 6 million a yacht no she goes can't
stay here that's what right yeah let's
can't stay here changed changed Amanda
changed right away oh yeah joy is this a
stupid iPhone it what the [ __ ] could use
it things have shamed Shane she gets
change on yeah she's always been really
frugal but like the other day before my
daughter's birthday she rented a giant
Hummer for 13 kids and took them out to
the this early 16 MTV show I was like oh
I was like hey man relax here would he
do with the home rule she spends way
less money i man I'm the [ __ ] she
spends on her kids I'll take that
yeah she's a great mom a beast but
whatever so you guys got a Hummer for
your kid though no no just don't one of
those big Hummer limos and all the kids
they don't like a standard h2 great
thanks Elly rap video to the gallon yeah
I used to have one of those you know
yeah of course you did although you're
so naughty yes you're so big I can see
AB if you're a big man I feel like that
would work for you mine was a straight
Arnold Schwarzenegger Hummer h2 that's
armies can big s wheels black wheels it
was fun am i no beast in the snow too
oh I bet beasts in the snow that's that
for you you should have I feel like you
think my 911s too small if I were you I
would have more hair on my face I'd have
a giant truck and a big working line
German Shepherd sable pull-up sable
working line German Shepherd please it
be a male
intact your dog should not be fixed and
it should be trained to the nth degree
you should just be too much for the
kiddos man I know but I'm just saying
bring up that yeah let's take a look at
keep going King because I want I want
you oh those are cute now keep going
keep going oh that's what it is
dude that's yours like yeah that's a
wolf that's a wolf dog be tough to
handle
it's called a man stopper actually
actually no they're great best dogs in
the world with kiddos - with kids in any
air anybody if you if you do anything
you wanna thing look snarling do
anything you want [ __ ] yes yeah there
are no are you gonna get seven of them
now they can dip them in gold I'm gonna
go I already have a female I'm gonna get
there it is that's what I look at that
thing
good coming to my house see what happens
dad the thing is sick yeah and they call
them light switches sweet dog to you
until you turn them on so you hit the
switch my buddy
it's got you you met Ryan who's got that
badass dog well yeah gardeners are there
and I go the dogs not doing anything is
why would the dog do anything I haven't
deployed him on the gardeners and the
gardener's are not acting in a an
aggressive manner deploy so why would he
do that
Jesus the only way that they he's gonna
he's gonna perk up is if they start to
come at him you don't want those
problems sure don't oh how was west palm
amazing did you go Restoration Hardware
um I went there every day
well yeah every day I had I went there
every I stayed there for three hours a
day like me too yeah just lounge around
the best and the vows well you know
olive trees the food's unbelieving
registration her office I can't so glad
you told me about that because I would
have been lost
you know what Starbucks every like every
day I go and instead I was there and and
and got to know the stat they came to my
show great
the best thing you can pick out
furniture and stuff yeah yeah then a
great love it 7 floors of Restoration
Hardware
that's restoration in Thomas top floor
on the French fries the chef how about
the lobster roll bro how about this that
they had a slow roasted chicken with a
no-shoe breed with roasted garlic
Izumi's juice that's right kids oh dude
might be the best [ __ ] so constantly
but so condescending
Oh show means juice stupids that's I
don't know why it's so funny
I don't either calling a group CD stupid
especially if you say stupids you're
stupid they're using that word
I want to be like anyway that's that's
I'm talking about global warming stupids
I've never heard that used that's so
simple so good it's so silly
yeah whatever stupid stupid is that the
500 people you know if you just bum you
guys didn't get that stupids yeah not my
fault
stupids loading it that way I'm funny
you got real speaking funny stupids
analyzing Steve Earle plural oh I saw
that movie you son oh wait back to Palm
Beach you got with Ryan loco got killer
solve some of the pics good here yeah
he's awesome this weekend isn't he great
yeah I know you should do with your
comedy I know you're like super famous
not bad but we should do is in Boston
booked the same weekend as Joe Rogan and
then when you're in Denver booked the
same weekend as Chris D'Elia is that
what's going on again you know what
though ya know so it helps my Sam good
I'm almost sold how could do both I'm
almost sold out in Boston but that's the
thing people go why would he book the
same way years D'Elia same weekend as
Rogan yeah but the thing is you're
you're at different venues yeah and you
can see D'Elia on Friday a fan of comedy
see Brian and satyr that's right I feel
like it helps 2% well my numbers are I'm
selling better than I've ever sold in
Boston and dinner so you know a lot of
that could be that also they know that
I'm better than than Joe and Chris no I
just mean better like overall like as
far as fun here bears
we don't know know just dislike be fun
yeah I just mean as a comic like when
you go like with me with Chris and Joe
okay that's alright I just mean that I'm
better that's what I do Lea he was that
for you or he was that but he posted a
picture just to cheers here's Brian
they're setting up for your show what
you did it's so [ __ ] funny
he's such a dick I want to show you
these [ __ ] Dahlia and and
Sasso like yeah I you know I just
floated out there that my show got
picked up you know just to see you oh
they're and they're the biggest
dicks they're just the worst you know so
I get I get this I go guys my spin off
got picked up for 13 apps I deserve it
and I just went I just won so
congratulations to me say it please oh
you're asking where the AI goes did it
really wow it's amazing
[ __ ] congratulations thank God huh you
needed it it's cool to have you on a 17
year old 17 year planned congratulations
Brian you sort of deserve it and let's
be sure see some cash from recommending
you for the role the first seven apps
after commission and tax ought to do it
then Marshall goes Congrats dude asked
me if I want to direct an episode that's
a circus ask me and then just out of
nowhere because hey guys got my cash
three years ago and never stand at once
Sasso came by an 8 is dinner while
lounging on it and in less than hour
well he shows a picture of just a beige
a terrible stain a basis and yeah yeah
and SAS goodness that's cuz I didn't eat
any beige that's mere dog soupy ass
anyway it was crazy it was crazy
oh so your friends are never there for
you let's be honest that's what you know
they did a study on how your life
expectancy the two factors that for sure
raise your life expectancy is being is
knowing and knowing friends having a
community that people that you can say
hi to like your mailman your community
and having people you can rely on in a
pinch really yep like people who you
could really rely on if you really if
you've murdered somebody
yes is it called or needed money in a
dangerous in a bad situation but when
you find out well it depends like
sometimes you want to help people with
they don't have money you know yeah yeah
also have also some people are the
architect of their own misery oh I know
the whole ways you know by giving money
it's not gonna solve it was a problem
just delays everything yeah there's and
I'm a sucker I'm a softie you are so
kind I
yeah I just tell me suckered night when
it comes my family outside that what's
that that's our battery power unit bomb
pretty cool meaning we need a new
battery chin gotta go out there and
violently oh but what's the show still
good yeah sure also I saw that movie
be quiet not is it be quiet or a quiet
place I think they say don't do that
every time movie shut up
you did I saw a new movie shut up shut
up that's actually a good name for it
I like be quiet what did I I want to
call my next special I have a boner um
what did boner Patrol know I want to
call my next special American boner I
like that wait tell America what do you
think of the movie very good but I gave
it a 9 out of 10 Wow
I need you to relax though I hold on
hold on cuz I don't watch movies well
you the last movie songs When Harry Met
Sally and I need her so when you saw
this like oh my god oh no watch lot of
movies how Bry old guy well no I'd the
movies damn good original it's such a
good movie I can't read last movie I saw
that guy's standing ovation at the NP
we're clapping yeah it's not a [ __ ]
it's a thriller suspense right not a
[ __ ] but it's fun you're on that you're
on the edges you stress the entire time
John I stuck paying expressing and
disturbed everyone's movie viewing
pleasure cuz the smell of orange chicken
and meat chomping on wontons
however the movie was fantastic yeah it
was really really good [ __ ] great I
know it's so hard to pull a movie off
like that cow oh my god you know Emily
Blunt I love the other Mary hashtag no
spoilers I loved the ending me too the
Deaf kid pissed me off a little bit
mister the kid she annoyed me too stupid
hey you listen do what you're told by
the way would you walk around on that
sand just walk around willy-nilly
I feel like think I stared bad all the
time but you know what after for a year
you like I'd [ __ ] this to kind of know
it this is my problem
don't don't just rip a fart game over ah
dad
girl here oh how about when you sneeze
or you got a cold and you got to blow
your nose I'll think about when you're
about to bust you have to yeah anyway or
what about when you everything running
water I don't know there's no you can't
do it be miserable those things are a
hideous they look you know what those
things look like fine they look like
they look like venom the mouth was like
venom from spider-man
the bodies were weird like the aliens
from the aliens movies but the mouth is
like venom they're doing the venom with
Tom Hardy plays venom the trailer looks
[ __ ] terrible cuz they didn't show
venom but the mouth should be like that
that movies [ __ ] good okay what and
innovation son yeah I'll tell you what
you die quick though with those things
you do I sense no herbal death now it's
not you know like I like a krokodil well
we'll pull you under and it's a tasty no
no those thing goes through those things
they just yeah you're done you get done
I'm gonna give a bit of a spoiler in
five four three two one in the beginning
where the kid yeah get smirked I almost
walked down the movie theater I don't
get down with that right now
I don't go the Meuse you have a child
yeah I don't get down with and you
realize what a what a horror show that
would be I won by the way I want the
deaf [ __ ] to die after that yeah and by
the way sir fault yeah certainly give
him the goddamn jet I know you stupid
[ __ ] I know I know don't call her a
[ __ ] but I know what you mean but also
Emily but and if you were if you're 14
but so stupids but if if you were back
you know in let's say it was going on
today I probably want to get my girl
pregnant right well duh not do that
whole family's in jeopardy of course the
babies come out how they can tell a baby
to be quiet I don't forgive it up or
what you give it okay a lot busting
loads inside your wifey while there's an
alien roam around that any sound yet
pull out and shoot heavy this is for you
you can't yell you can't say that you
can sign it though yeah yep yep it's a
beautiful you say what's going on denial
but how crazy though right
and you you're not safe you cannot lock
yourself in great movie yeah great movie
better than get out you're [ __ ] crazy
see for me it was no great my you know
what they're different it's not fitting
for different of different movies very
unique in both both what's not comedies
yeah get out was labeled as a comedy for
the Golden Globes that's [ __ ] insane
yeah yeah grab both great movies though
very it's a great movie Saqqara
I haven't did the second one the second
one comes out in June I've seen the
first one yeah how good is the oh my god
put my fear Emily Blunt the second one
looks badass what's his name she's a
good actress Emily Blunt
oh she's easy on the eyes it's easy on
the eyes phenomenal actress may I see
laughs oh there's a part to Chicago I
thought what it is don't leave you is
that it there yes yeah good planner well
the more the fans will see this now
really I just play a little bit other
things
don't [ __ ] with me children - I know who
you are you're the attorney who's family
it's such a badass in that day you know
the music sister co-authorship the music
gets me man the mute boy
same music as a as a be quiet more now
be quiet
oh you see the outer part - on my own me
and John Rogers called be quiet God he's
a good run and I'm so impressed that guy
yeah good movie man yep yup oh you've
gone this weekend I go to Boston this
weekend what Dave you leave Thursday
what time morning all right
look wha I mean I live in I mean live I
leave for a degree Thursday but not the
Thursday after you're gonna love Calgary
well my boy Scott and Dale are gonna
take care of you my boy Chris LaBelle is
gonna feature for you has that town
locked down here a lot of dudes names
being tossed around a lot so I'm all
filled to the brim not so if you said
Mary cereal Angie love is one of my
fantastic angie owns a club she'll be
there I'm sure to take good care of you
and and and you know i-i've given I let
I let Calgary know that they can give
you the green light
you don't do you know you don't do yeah
hold on
I know listening first of all shut up
shut up this party over a movie yep
secondly that's my town so if I love him
tell her if I want to shut you out I
make two phone calls bro but I open I
gave you the green light my boy Frazier
will probably be out there to see I got
friends dude well I'm just gonna hurt
tickets left for your friends I hate to
do that hungry
this is awkward do it yeah do it in a
normal was I just gonna hurt this I
don't know if they're oh god damn it I'm
excited for Calgary Jay Bruce headed up
there with me and then I'm doing a have
you done Minnesota I'm doing Mall of
Mosher half house comedy they're gonna
put you up the Madison the Radisson Blu
fantastic is it connected to the mall
America sure is the only reason I'm
doing this
I love Minnesotans yeah but so I can
stroll the Mall of America small America
there's an amusement park correct
they have seals and dolphins there and
there's Cinnabon hold I have seals
dolphins Cinnabon say don't say no more
fam you can buy anything you want there
you can buy swords you can buy some
daddy daddy
they got a store called flips just
flip-flops you buy any steroids touch
him in a sauna flips right now Tehran
one month a year daddy now that you're
famous rich can you just send some money
for Mall of America I'll give you my
plastic Oh crazy I don't give a [ __ ] is
my plastic plastic get crazy on that
what do you want go into the flip-flop
store my steel
hey Jeff anything with um with like I
want a shoe but with nothing like no top
to it this is a handle [ __ ] going to
there's another that just socks just
going to go hey Jeff shoes here let's be
a dick you everything that Justin will
fit I need I'm no um something that will
cover my feet with like cloth something
soft oh you my mom my mom was here you
missed her this weekend she always asked
about you shake wait we can't we go to
Brian's Mike he's not in town your mom
has a thing for me and I have a thing
for her bro straight up my mom loose in
the park yes I don't I let's tread
lightly here yeah do you [ __ ] my mom
no but horn before you answer did you my
mom listen mean they careful tread
lightly bro this is my mother talking
about I know
to my son to you you don't make those
gestures when you talk about me and my
girl you better be more respectful cuz I
know you're a tough [ __ ] dude but I
swear no security no I swear on my life
I will fight you and then I will have my
people [ __ ] you up
and then I'll sue you with my
high-priced lawyer and then you send me
a sex tape with my mom yeah bro this is
too much man we're both wearing masks no
for dirty ID my cuz you know we live
close to each other that's when I'm
driving past Ocean Park my longest
where's violin I'm like mom every time
it's there he lives there he's not in
town we just stopped by is a banner
they're like no no one's home no yeah I
think you menos there but you're my lie
your mom has a pair of shawl for me oh
she needs tickets for the Denver show
that's done anybody who you know she's
17 so I'm just kidding no no no she does
what you want she's going to you ain't
Krystal I got it all yeah well our has a
thing for you though she's the best and
hopefully you're our number you'll be
there too
nobody's coming nobody was out here with
Sue nobody's cute nobody was out here my
mom took over Center City now my mom
likes to point out every dog that she
sees and see the thing about LA is it's
a dog friendly town yeah so you get
nowhere because that's like point out
every Prius you see on the road we got
we move baby three steps at the mall
your family should know because you hear
it every time you you you kind of make
fun of them your family your dad we're
older mom they should all know that you
love them
oh I respect that all for sure and that
any time I joke around like this they
should never take it personally because
it's all entertainment no yeah my dad
got Matt the birthday thing didn't do
[ __ ] for my birthday and so he called me
it was very upset but you did nothing so
I get that no I know I get that you got
called a lot so I get what I know I know
he's getting me to send me another
message but you didn't often so that's I
said that so you need her don't take it
he's messing with you I'm just kidding
you did hook up with my mom yeah let's
he left me no choice but to hook up with
your wife no that's not what what please
do please do please do please get me out
of here so I got a freebie yeah you
don't want to bang the Brenin yeah there
was some girls yeah and there was some
girls teabagging written by my best
friend you offer me my business partner
OJ Simpson I'm fine by the way here's
the truth if you did if you did for your
a my your Hall Pass em I mean I that the
problem is we couldn't it couldn't be
like if we were like the anomalous
exactly usually in the morning like this
be like you banned my wife I'm never
speaking you again in this would be like
you know dude now the podcasts gonna be
super awkward
see you there that's like we have Brian
I have a singer AJ and I go dude you
hear about Brian show you in particular
of course I heard about it oh hell yeah
man this is really crazy year which is
talking he's like both you guys man I'm
so proud of you guys and you know
Brennan had an article in Wall Street
Journal about success no I'm not a big
deal yeah I know it's stupid no you were
so we were coming back from journalist
so we're going back to you I Wall Street
you I don't read it then the thing is is
so then we were going back and forth and
he goes god man with the firing the kid
like do you just I don't know man you
guys we're so busy I'm proud to be doing
that she'll be doing this like well were
you going with this story right now yeah
no neither once I ask that my Jimmy
Burke my dear dear friends like now are
you gonna do the if I don't kill I go
well yeah that's what got me here in a
lot of ways like I said it's also like
this this isn't work to me I'm never I
don't not once I've ever woke up in like
you know I get to go hang out with my
friend and a hawk the way I would anyway
and people on the road go do have like
how much like stuff do you guys write
down before the show you ready
never once have we ever in doubt make
sure we talk about this mad once we did
go through a phase where I cut where
we're like should we like talk
beforehand about what we're gonna talk
about and we're like we could try it
never
never happened no help doesn't work now
no it was wrong this way well it's just
it's it's we're having a conversation
but I never stopped doing it like this
is my outlet to be silly and do my thing
like I love the belt laughs you have to
cover some fight stuff yeah so you have
to play a character yeah you know you do
this stuff but this is this is different
we also own this it's completely
different because you don't own anything
on it no I make money too I don't own
anything on Showtime I own below the
belt podcast but that's my podcast I
don't own the show I make money doing it
and I love I'm far as a kid oh yeah yeah
yeah I love it so love it and the reason
that I sold so [ __ ] well in West Palm
and now it's just a place to sell Denver
is because of the fighter and the kid
fan correct okay yeah it's just a fact
same yeah so and God bless the Goldbergs
too but it's a lot of its I'm gonna
taste something I know I know
comics I just found this out really good
ones who have a TV show who have even a
special but they don't have a podcast
and they can't sell tickets and that's
it's just different they can't sell take
it it's different and that's what that
Wall Street Journal article was about to
do the road that's what that Wall Street
generally ideally you said it to me but
I didn't know you I'd have a little
subscript in it where the time out the
success of podcasting and touring live
yeah and the time out the serial podcast
time out some hitters and then they
talked there's a there's electrical the
bright made to senses chin right and
it's like you know bread and shop former
fighter with this hit of finding the kid
and blow the belt going over a double in
Australian that crazy still still in
wall street journal' it's a big deal for
the older folks yeah great let me know
great newspaper let them know
yep let them know it's the it's the
antidote chin did you say I don't know
if this current event I meant to send it
to do you have Oscar De La Hoya's news
[ __ ] no I'll look it up right now
now did you see the final hold on let me
just see in current events this type of
conversation all chanel hoya
new sex take come out what's probable
and it makes you want to party with him
even more now some people would say he's
a complete freak he's taking utensils
from the kitchen shoving up his anus
yes tried to extort so these two
Instagram models I told you be careful
these hoes Brian it's to Instagram
models I say that to everyone be careful
Instagram hoes yeah so these two escaped
models keep hitting them up to you know
fly hangs out with them they knew
exactly they're doing they set them up
apparently you want like spatulas and
baking soda put in his ass for the
reason he's a freak yeah bonafide free I
see that like you know what I want to
hang out with him yeah I'll have a
conversation sure I'm saying I'm down to
do this stuff but that's not film it
let's not do that let's get weird with
these hot girls don't film it correct
but he might have been high or you mean
Conor McGregor I John Jones I are the
same high in the same yeah correct
so I'm with you on this but love them
and by the way one of the great fighters
of all time
I got dressed up and I think but then
again I'm not a world champion not my
thing
however if the hottest girl in the world
were to come up to me and go listen I'll
do everyone I shouldn't put these three
digits in your anus I want okay I don't
need drugs or so I have a personal
question we might have gone over this in
the past okay this is a personal call
right go ahead shoot me I'll ask you
know have you ever had a girl she's
working you downstairs she's on her
knees whatever me sucking dick Brian
yeah
has she ever you ever had a girl stick a
finger I don't know we're right up the
old romper yeah if they have sharp nails
it achacha okay I have two and one girl
did it with a sharp nail and didn't feel
it but I lost it it's right quick so it
was unless the hard-on you lost no she
lost her nail in your [ __ ] no no I
lost I'm confused I busted oh you oh you
know how were you older because she is
that prostate is how over those 20 plus
I was 28 she hit that prostate probably
I don't know but I thought Levi got the
nectar of nowhere oh boy
got the nectar out and I just couldn't
believe it she got the nectar oh yeah
didn't know her it my first time with
her I'd known her for her aggressive
three hours that's a dress I was various
reals room she went knuckle deep in yes
right up the ass and by the way used her
thumb she
you mean the old hitchhike I couldn't
believe it one way please give me that
dirt our she'd done before with a sharp
nail but I didn't feel the nail Wow she
was Moreau [ __ ] you know a lot of
respect that I've got a risk I respect
that yeah I I had a girl one time when I
was younger push my feet back like I
remember I called you afterwards I
remember push my feet in the elastic is
a classy lady too little older classy
and push my heels all the way back I'm
not that flexible you guys know I'm
stiff Rosie Janice she gave it that she
was it like she was gonna change her
diaper like you're gonna change a baby's
type yes and it was embarrassing and I
my hard-on left yeah but she did go to
town on your left it went from [ __ ]
but she worked well she worked you're
gone she worked your balloon not with
her tongue right yeah did not enjoy it
no that's a little strange but did it
for a while yeah I felt I felt bad
Frankie and imagines almost I went from
the gym yeah yeah that's some girls
don't mind a gamey rump now here's the
thing some girls prefer a gamey rump I
would some guys do too I guess
did your well yeah I never I'm sure
you've had guys do that to you -
apparently but no I'm not I'm saying
some guys like to so that doesn't shout
and I didn't mean that oh I thought you
don't know cuz you said some guys I know
I messed up there I know it mess up I'd
mess much to admit it to some [ __ ] you
didn't call it no you're never happen I
don't care no but here's the bottom line
I can't imagine looking at a man your
size and saying I want count on a work
his balloon though I know after dinner -
you've been sitting on that rump I had a
fat piece of lasagna
yeah and now your your your your teeth
deep in my [ __ ] yeah teeth teeth my
friend told me his girl he was over her
and he was I guess his he was dropping
his I got a drop in the [ __ ] and he's
dropping his dong and her mouth that she
was on her back and I had to describe I
know and she started to laugh and
they've been dating a long time and and
he goes what she goes you know would it
kill you to not have dingleberries you
got dingleberries hanging like this it's
like I love you but I came off see oh
gosh right so I didn't take a shower not
him he's a man
thank you he's like alright let me go
wash I see I always keep it sexy I don't
care I want to bend a knee girl marry
whatever I always keep it sexy I don't
there's no farting there's no blown up
the bathrooms I I want to assume that
you that you're a princess and you don't
do the same things I don't like going
down that road I've never been that way
I don't burp in front of people I buddy
a little older and he decided to start
we were at the golf course and it was a
group of us a nice time he started two
exercises for his back before he did it
where the guide the chiropractor told
him to get on your hands and knees and
sag your back yeah
push it up his on his kind of khaki
shorts they were more you know they were
like a grey the shorts as always there
is a perfect diamond shaped who stained
oh let's see well I and you know us
we're all like hey [ __ ] pants you got
your [ __ ] your soupy ass went through
your underwear and uh yeah and he was
like it's an accident they're like yeah
it is dude and he played with that [ __ ]
stain it's a grown man grown man I don't
play golf in a while I'm 10 years old
that I think that's still part no it's
all theirs
ah did you uh Oscar De La Hoya man I
like him and those those [ __ ] you know
they said they went to like vivid
personal thing try selling and that guy
goes well that's extortion report them
ok and now they think that whoever the
people are all over it now okay should
we they'll get in troubling there Joe
for that you know I'm also if the girl
is makes her living showing her ass on
Instagram chances are she's she's drawn
to a certain kind of attention and
attention like that is very important to
her
so it's not shouldn't be surprising this
she's gonna use a celebrity to also get
more attention that's how I look at they
know and then we can hear I don't care
what kind of tension it's gonna be now
no there's a there's a huge few red
flags you can tell with girls like that
that that's a good point not being able
to decipher between
good attention and bad attention yeah
they don't write C and in a good kind of
example here's so that Tristan Thompson
cheated on Chloe card her cheating on
Khloe Kardashian well he cheated on his
current baby mama with Khloe Kardashian
when she was 16 or 13 months pregnant so
he did that to her left her for Khloe
Kardashian
you know what that mother of his child
said she goes I'm not gonna thrive in
the sadness of cloaker - anything like
that she's I wish him the best hope they
figure it out I went through it - yeah
but she's like I'm not gonna celebrate
him doing this to her - class doesn't
want the attention she's very attractive
I bet super classy well yeah that's cool
good for her good for her now where we
talk about the fights yeah I drank too
much coffee
I watched the fights and I I actually
really enjoyed I enjoyed them and I
watched I mean how great was that made
of that I just engage heat and I think
you would said this before but like you
can't as tough as he is with those crazy
leg kicks taking that punishment you
know turtling up and I'm oh this is you
can't do that I guess the example I gave
on below the belt see if you vibrate
this bribe just engaging me is that he's
at one kid in college or high school
who's the life of the party his life the
party we all enjoyed it we all watched
it just like we watched Justin gay -
I'll watch it we all loved it so much
fun we don't to be him we like him and
spurts and we're watching super
entertaining and we all know that movies
not gonna end well but yet we still
fought we still hanging out with her
just engages that he's nobody counties
the crazy guy but it doesn't end well so
if like I watch that go between I went
holy [ __ ] that's amazing fight but this
part of me goes oh that poor guy yeah
well your name another fire he suffered
that much damage that short well he's
had three fights in the UFC you name
another guy who suffered that much he
can't change [ __ ] in Strikeforce he was
taking this kind of all World Series
World Series you can get away with that
yeah you're gonna beat those guys UFC
you're not beating on that Dustin
Poirier the press the the stipler spirit
guys aren't gonna put up with there
you're gonna you're gonna get them in
trouble but eventually those in come out
on top oh yeah oh he's always oh yeah
you can't your head can only take so
much and you know some guys like Goethe
had this crazy chin
but it's just so bad for you and I and
it the more we know about like it just
shortens your career it shortens Feith
goes I think he goes I have five fights
left in my career yeah I would say
that's been pretty yeah optimist yeah I
like that I don't think so too tough for
his own good like an amazing warrior but
too tough for his own good the
frustrating part is he's a natural he's
all-american wrestler phenomenal
wrestler whether one the best wrestler
I've seen Wow but our great great
athlete he condemned in every backflip
everything you you want him to kind of
like you want a guy like that to kind of
like fight differently but but what the
way he defines himself how he made his
name is he's so excited yeah the most
violent man you see the problem with
that though too is like his his default
is in when he gets in trouble like if
you're Frank Mir if you're Nogueira a
lot of guys who hit your default goes oh
[ __ ] let's buy some time here let's
wrestle and grapple here's background
his wrestling his default should be
wrestling yeah he doesn't do that his
default because of the way he's wired
goes
let's throw back let's still that's fire
back yeah which is crazy
I don't like it just shows you a cut
type of duties which we love them but in
10 years you it's gonna be sad well it's
like look at watching somebody who's
yeah yeah I don't like seeing somebody
like that I don't like seeing their
destroy him like that when Mohammed II
was kind of done watch him get battered
like this came after the Foreman fight
he fought 38 more times and [ __ ] and
took real punishment the team around him
knew he shouldn't take it too and you
you know you what you're watching
mahalo leaves differences than that
entertain with gay chi we know it's
entertaining but we also know it's super
unhealthy we know this for a fact as
athletic as Jesus could he'd pull a
robbie lawler where he fights
differently where he changes his style
is it possible he can you know a skills
for sure like why not fight more like
Dustin Poirier all right she can't fight
like that's important he's not
technician at all he's not he's not his
leg kicks great he's good in the clinch
his boxing is all right he's pressure
brake you typing you can do that and be
a grappler though you can do that you if
he's gonna model any grab grab he could
be right be could do it could be right
now yeah yeah yeah be khabib just just
let just try it out for one fight for a
lot of it's a lot of it's being it's not
a lot of it's not a race
embracing how your been label but net
and not yeah now it's nope you're the
most vitamin in the UFC Dana White's
gonna suck you off you can get this huge
bonus I promise you that
that's like given signing bonus that
it's not there's no longevity in that
all you're getting is this huge lump of
money are in front but there's no
longevity and I've said this to fighters
I've said this to other people who were
actors but don't let anybody define you
because when you let people to find you
especially the people saying good things
about you that that's a trap too because
now you're gonna try to fulfill who they
support rotations don't listen to people
man do your thing and and and and change
and think and readjust your approach
it's tough because if you're adjusting
so many people going to course it allows
us and Dana's gonna do thank you that
that's great here's your bond your bonus
and but it's like what if you're just I
think sit down and go where am I if I
lose two more really gonna do with me
yeah now Dustin Poirier looks fantastic
got to worry about some leg cakes again
there's really no no I mean besides
maybe you know there's a few guys who
could like kick him but he I mean you
think it through just engage he's like
kicks you're good he's keeping the in
the gutter so you're good now who's next
for him well I said well I'd say maybe a
title shot because really with Tony
first out for a while probably here he
had surgery so he's a big scar and then
with Conor we don't know just kind of
wanna fight legal troubles hopefully
does fight then you get Connor could be
but if he doesn't then it's down to
Eddie Alvarez in Dustin Poirier I'd
rather see Dustin Poirier fight cubby
I think tubes a bigger favorite over
just imported than he is that he
operates because of his wrestling yeah
yeah if if of course if I'm Dustin
Poirier I'm I'm doing everything I can
I'm gonna taunt khabib I'm gonna say
you're afraid to stand with me he would
never stand them he's gonna do that
boring fighting style again and I would
do everything I could to get him you
know I'd do if I was could beam how he
says you know I'm a real champ I'll
fight I want to fight oh and be active I
would fight I'd tell the UFC this I tell
Eddie Alvarez and desperated this so I
don't take any fights I'm gonna fight
Dustin Poirier first in two months in
four months after that I'm fighting a
virus hold right
they're boys and I walked through both
of them and create that even more you
think he walks through both those guys I
think Eddie IRA is a tougher matchup but
I think he wants both of why I say the
Albert Eddie I was a really good
wrestler you know a lot of power at that
same level though not to no nowhere near
the same level but the higher level than
Dustin Poirier it has knocked out power
you know and he's fought the best of the
best
Eddie Irish was world champion the UFC
world champion Bellator you know he came
from you know dream like Daddy I was a
[ __ ] monster yeah
phenomenal fighter what do you think a
Condit cowboy thing oh I need to be I'm
surprised cowboy was a Brazilian cowboy
not daus aronia I surprised
cowboy Oliveira was a favorite and I was
it kind of really figure out a plot
favorite coast Condit then you watch the
fight and it's just like you know Carl
Conner gotten caught in that back in the
day I feel yes i right but the problem
with con it too and either placing bets
on more if you're a fan of his is when a
guy goes I'm done I'm retired and come
back out it's never it's not really good
that's that from day one
it's never good you talking a guy who
was one foot in one foot out yeah Carlos
I always thought he was like number two
forever in the 70 pound weight class I
mean as good as it gets for a long time
yeah that's some phenomenal fights but I
love when you're talking about how
you're done it's like and what you think
of style bender do you see him um there
is one Israel kid of a son yeah no I
didn't he's like he's like the no yeah
Jesus yeah Keller yeah for mama yeah
good for a great flight is that where
he's from is he from oh is it that's his
name no he's he's from Africa but he's
out of New Zealand he's raised he's a
beast
athletic he fights out of Auckland New
Zealand but he I'm pretty sure he's born
in Africa is that right chin look at my
races Lauren in nigerian-born New
Zealand you go yeah yeah Kym box alright
super freak standbys holes in a day
didn't you get submitted by um no he's
undefeated him who you think who was the
guy who got submitted by the wrestler
that the Russian wrestler honest honey I
watched him phenomenal movement
phenomenal yeah casings
submitted the last of the last
when undefeated
Marvin vitória I feel like more of a
toys the big Italian guy who can want to
take him down big kid I think must
Natori and up tapping him
Ono is the Russian got the other guy
okay nevermind I'm sorry what are you
thinking of um Vettori end up with his
life it was it was last guy but towards
amid the last guy yeah no there was no I
was thinking about Muslim sonic off with
Ricky Rainey the hallways are yeah
Binaca yeah Brad Tavares look great to
me wait go so so so I was flying on the
radar Sonya did what he defeated he did
beat his ass okay ah I would say beat
his ass he was a split decision I think
it was he won a majority decision but
you saw holes in this game finally well
you surprised by the Antonio Carlos jr.
defeat of Tim Boetsch no no I think
Tim's been doing for a long time you
know Tim Tims kind of like that
semi-truck you just keep coming but yeah
yeah I loved him he's been doing for a
long time but College juniors a freak
yes right good fight since there's more
fights this weekend to who's fighting
this weekend ah Kevin Lee Barbosa
main event you got Frank yo your Cub
Swanson Frankie of month off after
getting knocked out by Brian Wyatt a guy
that it's in like City County's hometown
you know a terrible idea
Harold I can't I can't think that
terrible idea I don't understand that
look at those two my boy Pat Cummins is
fighting enjoy that [ __ ] enjoy that boys
you met Pat right coming
oh that's a good fight yeah how's it
coming sir yeah great that's great fight
for Pat and that guy's ranked 10 it's a
good fight both ten-four but he's so
rockin an awesome mustache yes fantastic
muster bet your sweet ass he is I'm very
happy with that must actually handsome
dude go ahead get that tooth fixed no
because I'm character let's get back and
get that tube sex
Sterling's fighting it's good for card
man Jim Miller salt card Jim Miller main
event still fights still doing it man he
saw my brother as a beast too
all right Colonel Vance so West Palm
Beach did you see Casey Anthony no is
there any chance you could have saw
holdout of Bonnie Anthony she's in the
murder trial right huh they thought she
murdered a kid stupid [ __ ]
boy I'm just very aggressive solo
drinking an Irish pub chats a local bar
flies goddang Kelly that is O'Shea is
Irish pub is there anywhere in West Palm
Beach yeah I don't know how or if that
there's got only one spot in West Palm
right
I don't know what she's not with that
person what did they ever find out she
got acquitted as you did it though do
people talk with her
oh she's problem I don't know what that
is when you murder a child she can take
its toll on you she's not looking great
yeah I don't take its toll on your life
I think people leave her alone I think
you're a little crazy maybe you were a
little like we don't know exactly what
happened and I think it's just one of
those things where you're like all right
you know by the way celebrity is weird
celebrity will have people taking
pictures not a celebrity though she's
just just chatting it up with a local
bar people there oh good how does she
make money she did kill her kill kid
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh she get Jen this one
another TMZ one so right Mariah Carey's
ex manager is suing her for sexual
harassment and a bunch of other stuff I
guess the MRI would always walk around
naked and she would do sexual things to
herself in front of her ex-manager I
just good time strange oh the hurt that
hurt it's a female x-man another female
yeah that's probably Mormon she's not
bad looking either no she's not but I
also feel like those kinds of things are
you be that disturb I think that that'd
get annoying no I wouldn't be but she's
trying to don't you feel like this is a
little bit like my sister Zoey yeah it
sounds like you're trying to get back at
somebody and you're
suing somebody for sex another woman for
second year maybe she did it once or
twice you know I know but it's your
manager and what does that mean and you
know oh there you go
so claims she was unfairly fired in the
middle of a three-year condo is still do
a ton of cash mm-hmm she's giving us an
opportunity yeah I mean you know I'm
saying
and so now Mariah will make it also go
away I think I think it's a [ __ ] move I
think it's also really bad man because
also from Angela that's not where that
truckers silhouette of a naked chick on
your hair that's not we man you know
what good point well seocheon it's just
nasty man nasty my buddies that [ __ ]
trial lawyer and he tells me the
craziest stories about that oh my god
it'll bum you out
Mariah Carey aging like a piece of fruit
not wine let's be real she's a long time
killer she looks like my sister to be
honest with you she looks a little like
your sister
your sister has a thicker mustache Arai
is a big girl my sister has a goatee big
dick I mean I'm just being honest my
sister has a dick this is sad John Cena
this girl split up they were just they
just cutting it's not [ __ ] I don't care
but it's not sad it's awesome cuz now
that means that Nikki Bella's single
yeah I mean who just got who never seen
her and her twin sister I had to bring
them all
you are in for a treat get your cuz I'm
already like I'm at a I'm already can't
you advise to take out and I'll spit on
my head don't know what's going on with
me today I want to fight all that you
fired up you sure got picked up I
appreciate it and I'm I guess these are
those - I'm sorry - Oh problem with that
don't care Brian or no sisters those are
totally honest and sisters stars the dub
dust dust nothing comes out flat
prostate um they're delicious
there are some hottest women on earth
Brian who are they they're The Bella
Twins they have their own show on E and
they're also the stars the WWE Diva
Chin's on them they're they're beautiful
no hey man no they have strong shoe I
will defend them to the dozer Sam I
defend I may not kill you they're just
big all of I kill you I mean to rip your
[ __ ] they cause they're amazing then
once single now chin sets sad news and
chin is single hmm yeah I'm not getting
any of those girls for sure why chin
what see that's the problem if you're
single you're John Cena if you're saying
oh you're you're you're you can have you
can have a full rolodex you just be very
busy because I know what you would do
right now you'd slide right in them DMS
does she is like 19 million five she
ain't seen the big enemy you'd find your
way through you think she never even
knows I can beat up John Cena
you might be funnier than me have you
seen him in his movies he's great he's
aloose great I like that there was a guy
who was warning you about a group of
people who there's a there's a guy who
yeah and the guy was like guys his
entourage is kind of tough and then
somebody was with you and they go do you
know that Brennan could beat the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of his entourage and that guy
guys I really yeah so silly I know you
could be none of that although I don't
know if I could he's um he's a Brian
he's so tough you'd have to have to
you'd have to sock his face and he
apparently is not an athlete I've talked
to Don minute well you know what I'd
rather just be his friend
I don't wanna fight anyone I'd rather do
a movie with that man or do more in a
podcast he is a big boy I've never
disown awkward I met his awkward body
madam one time never seen wrists and
hands and he's a weird but not a bad way
just different when it's like it's very
he's very blocky you know he looks
exactly how a GI Joe should look if they
turn this room like it's good point he's
exactly proportionate
how a GI Joe is which is human form
right and he has flattop not be fear him
he kills it like in trainwreck is out
new movie [ __ ] blockers he Solaris I
think he's the next rock in two years I
think he's doing the same action movies
as the rock really he's huge man he's
getting more roles and what they're
doing their self-deprecating roles where
they're funny you know good that's what
whether or not you know you don't be
[ __ ] dick yes great this is set at it
Donnell he was so nice to me twenty
years ago whenever I met him fifteen I
asked him a question and how many years
ago yeah the cold Jim I asked him um I
asked him a question oh you're that guy
don't know bro bro you got big lats
right I you know I do it so weird I mean
I would I asked him about something they
were they were sold off in the song said
something about shorts I don't remember
any I can't run with the conversation
was but he was so [ __ ] cool I looked
at his wrists and hands I went
it's the biggest wrists and hands about
yeah he oh yeah he said he said some
like um I go I'm gonna get some shorts
over there that was shorts over there
and he goes they not for me I can't fit
in the shorts man my legs in my ass just
don't fit it yes - it seems like a good
dude
great guy and pure like god I wonder
what happened life just life I'm sure
with this schedule I came in my
schedules busy as [ __ ] yeah I'm terrible
person to date terrible I can't imagine
being John Cena yeah you have so that
you're never around
you're never home my kids punish me for
it I was gone
and rightfully so my kids are like oh
who's the stranger get out oh my god pay
bills they're like [ __ ] you're not with
me
get out yeah like who's the girl you're
with right now I'm like she's my
girlfriend she's living here for a while
I want to see my wife's upset about it
could I do that I'm on TV now yep you
don't leave us a long series so what are
you being a baby about correct the shoes
I paid for a little bit she's like well
who are these kids I go I had kids with
this other chick or two half-brothers
stupid say hi that's your half brother
stupids when we get all the family
together
hold on up and start this off by saying
stupids this is your half-brother John
Cena dead list 602 pounds it just says I
believe that with
is frame for sure yeah what else get
chin I don't say this is set stir again
with slurries breaking up though you
know I mean I don't fury it's both of I
just got engaged not really together for
six years I don't got him so he avoided
in marriage why cuz this movie crews a
boom in and not for a guy that has ever
sad a lot of breakups in Hollywood yeah
alright the next one in life can in life
to the next is not for you to get your
heart broke not in a mean way I'm just
saying like take some swings is what I
mean that's probably why I'm not taking
a swing your skill you hurt bro you
never know it's been broken before
hasn't it of course everyone's hard
though is that why you don't that's why
you don't do hard you're a pansy is that
its guard spending is hearts like a
fabricated blender yeah sensitive guy
somebody somebody poured salt on it
that's what you don't do it all you're
scared to get hurt broken I don't know
maybe who knows junior Cray with
emotions next week that's what it is
circular oh that guy earlier Locke
passed away he was great now my favorite
Rolf his when he was in frighteners but
that's not a big deal
he was great are you know bragging debut
I died at 74 that's young to die yeah
that is young he was actually in the
Marines it's how he got his big on the
food metal jacket he got you a sergeant
in the Marines right yep he was so good
oh no I'm sorry not frighteners i
[ __ ] love him in saving Silverman
he's the football coach and he does a I
heard that and throws the first down
marker and kills a ref and they put in
prison so they go to him for advice he
goes you kill her they're like well no
he can't kill you they kill her no mmm
he goes where she had the or how she
goes you go down you tell her and they
just like alright well we'll see you
later
it's Keith [ __ ] here the grace he's
so funny in that man five six sir holy
Sh I don't know if I'll [ __ ] that I man
man what a great guy what he died from
saying real ammonia pneumonia get your
man if you're older you just can't fight
it yeah my son got pneumonia because I'm
used to seeing old people die was I
freaked out
like mmm he's young unless they're like
infants he should be fun dog your dog
kennel cough so got a my inta biotics
what that's stupid Corgi you know you're
famous rich just kill that thing smart
dog
let's do something about you the best
I've ever had
be smart oh yeah so cute and smart he's
a badass bite you too
mmm bite your [ __ ] face he'll bite
you and your goddamn Achilles heel and
don't [ __ ] around with him no bite yet
you look killer
okay so Coachella was this past weekend
all right yeah and that little kid the
Walmart kid yeah remember him yodeling
inside a Walmart yep he actually
performed at Coachella in front of this
enormous he was super viral so everyone
else he is what was this video that was
so big I'm just gonna oh he's saying I
Hank Williams song in a Walmart and then
people just loved it I was up to see
that trick I'm not familiar well good
you know Coachella annoys me can I say
that I got a bunch of friends they're
going to it and all that [ __ ] this
weekend because of Coachella The Grove
was dead
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
20 million views for whatever reason
it's resonating with people and then
even in the audience at Coachella people
want crazy for him to really yeah they
all recognize them does he see yeah
[Applause]
and he has like zero fear he just goes
up and does it Wow
kuk-ja I ain't gonna catch Ella
no I'm everyone's going to know it's all
crazy about that I'm told for it young
for any man I don't do that stuff thirty
minutes a little burnisher it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] that goes on our brain man so I
appreciate it let's take a journey up
there just for the stories yep just for
the stories just do some just some Molly
and then do some do some who knows maybe
just you and I in it for a bit no no we
we can own ourselves in mud and wear a
loincloth yeah in red mud I want to be
covered in red to go devil horns and
with red mud twins come on down oh you
only have gummy bears for currency huh
gummy bears and dick yep what else you
got chin this is that Coachella to
Justin Bieber according to witnesses
Justin Bieber punched a guy in the face
that was actually attacking a girl well
I dig that there's nothing wrong with
that good for him in very good he boxes
raft I already his Boy Floyd Mayweather
they're not friends anymore like each
other why hey welcome to on a team right
all right women friends like two three
calm who's contacted the victim who
declined to press charges
well that's cool yeah cuz he knows used
in the wrong I was it mad at Bieber's
out but I had no visible injuries if I
unload on a guy with her right Brandon
you're pressing charges you gotta get a
nose redone you don't I mean gonna have
your job because he controls what I
caught if I throw my right I'm gonna
have to game over
goodnight good for Biebs doing that
though his outfit was pure fire at the
Coachella you know attending these days
is like the Hawaiian Japanese like loose
flower design shirt really it got myself
one you did yeah let me see it's a cross
between weekend at Bernie's and being
awesome
that's right huh that's it I don't know
don't hold on no the shirt I dig the
pants the Hat and the the shoes are
[ __ ] terrible the shirt those are
those are in right now not to that level
but they're in like gee look at jeez
he's outfit with uh [ __ ] car DB he's
Mieke though Justin Bieber he's cool I
like him talent like click on that this
one clean out the one that one like
that's it that's it right now be you can
put that smell off yeah
that's G easy and his girl Halsey who's
G easy he's a singer I know is he is he
a rapper like Robert he's phenomenal
though you cannot know where it's here I
didn't know who's out the day that's
like old school vibe to him his fashion
is pretty good though these girls Halsey
and he says he likes her he loves her
and she also likes women so they have
fun let that thinkin Brian oh and she's
gorgeous she's and she's super she is
delicious she's a singer too
oh yeah bro really oh man she is like
that hits both of them it's never hit
together called crazy love what yeah
she's adorable
oh yeah when you're talented and you
sing like that
oh her voice is so unique - I don't like
your short hair I do she's got a great
voice
let me yeah hole the-- let me hear your
wrecking balls I'll do alone you should
have went to the live one for why
see see below there Halsey there we go
welcome Brian
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
never wait for the course
[Music]
one love Brian the drummer's got a hood
off huh
one love brother they're great it's
amazing how how how much black music has
influenced white singers they basically
copy rap and all the blues singers can
you imagine American culture without the
african-american influence we'd be
boring or Thank You black people one
love you know I'm saying one love black
people
yeah can you imagine music without the
blues without I mean all that stuff yeah
for sure just in a weird past but I'm
just telling Halsey killing it man even
though I touch it I'm kickin it let's
see your turtle and tortoise jump even
their language when they're like y'all
can't give it I'm kicking it holy
even the hand gesture white less
privileged get less wet just white white
doors copy black artists yeah don't good
let us get Jim
this one's a crazy story so there's a
woman who's already killed two people
one was her ex-husband I believe in the
next one was they look alike so she can
steal her identity
woman man I've almost killing look-alike
mm-hmm
so she can steal that woman's identity
oh sure
shooting Wow but they're still looking
for she's on the loose right now
California Florida that's what what she
was yeah
Palm Beach I don't know if it was
probably 56 year old woman 56 [ __ ] be
well doesn't you know evil has no Brian
yeah how's your braces personals hey hey
I think you link you know their
psoriasis models I do you still hope
remember me that [ __ ] me up because of
how bad psoriasis can get I didn't
realize I can get up on your face those
girls just owned it and they're models I
would ruin my
Duhamel shoot the new show I would get
spray painting your face you'd have to
you have to cover me up something fear
and math what else get chin
[ __ ] that [ __ ] killer the last one is
that angels player he's a Japanese kid
he's like all the honey what about him
he has so many fans especially women
fans that are going crazy that they have
to tell him to calm down during the game
he's a Dreyfuss he's a good-looking dude
for yeah oh wow yeah he's the pitcher
pitcher and hitter oh wow yeah if you
can ask him so people are just digging
them especially young young girls young
Asian girls are all grown off they're
Asian he might be then by changing
population might be just an orange town
it's the young Japanese pop it has to be
the young Japanese then yeah let's see
yep the women young Japanese or Japanese
exchange students oh yeah well they're
like let's get some more pictures of
this guy I got to take him in all right
I'll take him you're doing are you a fan
of his to chin or no are you a baseball
fan even a baseball fan but I heard a
game is baseball huh too many games are
based off from the young bored until
October oh it's got a cute face he looks
like a honestly he could pass for like a
Korean pop star if he did go that
direction yep he's a good-looking kid
yeah but he's Japanese Japanese look at
him six big dude yeah yeah yeah it's
that kid drinks milk that's what happens
to a Japanese kid drinks milk um
interesting you know the before World
War two in Japan you you just never saw
a six-foot tall Japanese person and then
with the introduction of a Western diet
they've all got bigger yeah that's weird
in fact it was very common I think the
average height before World War two is
something pretty low life or you know we
should do you look that up hell you
brother advertised Asia and stuff like
that you know should do for lunch to
celebrate two sugar fish I would agree
with that dude I think we've earned it
you've earned it can't enjoy a little
you know five foot three inches tall was
the average height and they weighed
between 160 120 pounds so you're saying
don't eat a fish rice Dora was at a
Japanese soldier before World War two
and then there was no such things you
know I got one for your old ass you
pad thai was developed in like 1940
something probably and they developed it
just for like Americans
yeah the noodles did it wasn't before
then it wasn't really the thing it's not
like your old family tradition in Asia
in rice
yeah no they came up with it look up
look up the the history genius in 1938
cuz they were like alright let's create
this but before you I didn't know that
Jason's culinary critic card like some
genius in the in the kitchen looked at
here in 1938 features earlier better
known as five bun and Western historical
accounts had played a private role of
military officer and coupe that stripped
Thailand's monarchy of absolute powers
all right okay became the prime minister
okay he worried about his country's
independence most of all support for his
rule okay where the [ __ ] this pad thai
coming I don't I stays is not a foreign
creation like General Tso's chicken
whenever we try to hide food chef and
Thailand native Nick whatever we tripod
Thai first because that is a way to
judge how good a restaurant is pata is a
staple of bangkok street food and sold
this didn't do it justice but yeah
there's a see they just created pad thai
out of the blue yeah and it was it like
a old school tradition like sushi or
something like that or sashimi or well
tomato sauce come from italy tomato
sauce came from the new world Italian
herbs creature and also orange chicken
didn't come from China I and expressed
did buy in China right you know did you
see that a fee are they getting up fired
for uh James coming did you see his oh
you see it is he goes he's not a stupid
man he's morally unethical to me yeah to
be President he's pretty fascinating
it's really fast in yeah yeah it was
cool he's always known sure yes is
agenda to he's not outside some books he
and the truth are not always you know
you sell them books do that James well
the best thing you can do is if you
write a book the greatest thing to ever
happen it's country to tweet about
shitty in it when she did the best thing
that happen to your book correct let's
go eat [ __ ] sushi and celebrate your
let's go do it and you're paying for
time see me this way to Boston go see
brennon in calgary no and then how
Greece back Calgary sold-out there's
like 10 tickets but those are sold out
I'll be in Minnesota May 4th and 5th
Mall of America May 4th and 5th
Minnesota and then West Nyack New York
May 11th through 13th there you go there
you go West Nyack New York DFAC a comp
Rossville Denver at the end of the month
and I got collusive casino May 5th so
come out Stillson take a slapper
Okaloosa go see him Denver T back here I
come now so these the one love
bryan callen reggae Rasta where's my
yoga vibe your shirt's over there those
drop soon t back a calm on this grandma
post the exact date and time we will be
dropping the new one love t-shirts with
Bryan Callen Congrats brother this is a
good one today this is the fine kid
we're out
you